i remember the first time that maylene
messaged me like to work with bulk
walker yeah i thought it was a scare
honestly honestly i i thought the same
thing as well
i was just like i was just like i was
like no way this is real hold on a
second it says
i'm like the cuddle color nah and i i
swear the first one i [ __ ] deleted it
immediately i was like nah that's a scam
get out of that and then meleen misses
me like emailed me again after a week
and she's like i don't know if you read
my last email but uh we're interested in
working with you and i'm like
oh this [ __ ] shouldn't delete that again
oh there was a it was a youtuber who uh
they got uh
like offered a role to voice an anime
yeah by by funimation right and that was
a scam and they publicly announced
that they'd gotten the role right in the
show
and it was just a fake email
oh my god that was like that is i don't
think i've cringed out of body in pain
for someone else more of my life i i
laughed but that was that is just that
is just that that's a that's a bro
moment if
i did that [ __ ] and i found out it was a
scam i would just quit socially i think
i would i think i would
yeah
yeah also you know generally when you
get roles and stuff you supposed to kind
of you're not supposed to say you're
right
yeah so i guess maybe it was like a test
it was like yeah no rules for you gotcha
it's like willy wonka it's like ah you
were too greedy no role for you maybe it
was really funimation they just needed
to pass the test
it's like indiana jones like the holy
grail yeah ah you chose greed no
no because like going back going back to
the book walking emails that we first
got i think i i think looking back
maelynn must have emailed me way earlier
before i actually replied for the first
time yeah and what caught me to reply
was meeting you for the first time and
being like oh yeah that that email from
megalin that did you get an email for
mailing as well and i was just like
that's not a scam that's real
that was real this entire time
i remember i've just been ghosting her
and deleting all the emails i remember i
think that i think i sent that email to
about like
three or four different family members
just to be like does this look fake
because i'm really scared to reply to
this [ __ ] and get like a virus because
like i don't even know luckily it wasn't
but uh yeah yeah i don't know if it was
the way that like mainly wrote the email
or what it was yes i'm playing blaming
maylene
i don't know i think i think it was just
before this was before the point of
annie tube where
we thought any kind of companies yeah
like yeah
because before that like the biggest cup
like i had not worked with any big
company right it was always like you
know like that's true actually like yeah
it was it was not i was still tiny back
then as well so i was like no no i i
can't this jump is too high that's way
too unrealistic
i mean yeah i mean arguably book walker
kind of like paved the way in that way i
feel like bookwalker opened up i took
the bullet for everyone yeah yeah
yeah
i was like i'll take it for the for the
good of the people
did you see this the youtube scam though
did you see what like
i saw what it was about because i think
literally ever all of my other friends
got that email including you guys and uh
yeah and so i was scared i was i was
sifting through my email as well and i
didn't get one it's so essentially what
happened was is that i got an email from
a google email yeah that said oh uh uh
the message was sent like oh you have a
duplicate adsense account um
and you know your channel will be
deleted and i think that is one of the
rules of adsense is that if you do
actually have multiple adsense accounts
you will yeah yeah you get banned yeah
that you can only have one adsense
account and they do send an email like
that as well
yeah i only have one adsense account but
uh we had multiple channels so maybe i
thought oh my god there must be a mix up
because you know i recently just had the
new channel and yeah you know yeah it
was kind of but this is often how scams
work though as well they prey on
very coincidental circumstances that
have been happening outside of the scam
itself yeah yeah you know like jim
browning said in his thing it's like
yeah sometimes you order you just order
the product on amazon 10 minutes later
you get a scam email about amazon yeah
people
pure coincidence but it happens to play
off a little bit right yeah concerns so
yeah it's this thing and the one thing
that was probably the red flag which i
think
did make me unsure but again i was kind
of so worried that i was like oh i
should just i i went to hear him out at
least it was through google hangouts
yeah but it was a google email so i was
like okay well it's a bit weird because
normally they would just but then again
i've never had correspondence through
google because there's no [ __ ] at
talking to you yeah i don't even know
how they would reach out to me yeah
because they've done email in the past
but sometimes they haven't so i don't
really understand i think that also is
one of the reasons why people did fall
for them yeah because youtube is so
unclear and how they reach out i mean i
mean the the only the only time i've
ever talked to google directly live
through twitter yeah yeah i've spoken to
them i've never had someone reach out to
me yeah yeah it never happened so i so
i'm talking to them and they're going
through the thing and they're like oh um
yeah you have a duplicate adsense
account and i'm like that doesn't sound
right i don't have the duplicate adsense
account they're like oh well you do and
i'm like okay well what's what's the id
on the adsense adsense accounts of ids
yeah and he gave me an id and it was
just like not even remotely close to
anything and i was like oh um okay well
that's weird and i was like um can you
tell me about the account then what's
what's the duplication and you just
couldn't tell me anything yeah it's all
private it's all private which would
would kind of make sense you know yeah
and i was like okay well fine fine all
right well i was like can you tell me
that you're a google employee can you
show some proof and he was like no
and i was like
because i'm not
like all right scooby doo mask reveal at
this point and then what he was trying
to do and he was um you can make
multiple youtube accounts under one
email yeah and so he told me to make a
new youtube account
um so i did this because i was just
curious to see what the steps he was
telling me to do were yeah because i
knew none of this was permanent and
doesn't really matter if you make a new
account yeah it doesn't like delete
anything so he told me to make a new
youtube account and then go to the
youtube uh account management page and
then set to have the new account that i
made take over the old channel now what
this does is that it deletes all the
videos right and deletes everything
especially like a factory reset it kind
of just puts like it's just like this
channel it's like and you know
plaster it on top yeah yeah yeah yeah
brand new
nothing else was here before right
that's kind of it it's a cover-up right
yeah and then you know so and it just
deletes everything yeah and then he was
telling me to do that and and so i got
to the point where i i clicked on like
the i wanted to see what the menu was to
do it and i was going through steps and
it was like oh yeah it'll delete
everything except for like likes and
comments and stuff and i'm like what the
[ __ ] that's weird
but uh and and then i was like no this
doesn't seem right this this seems a
little weird yeah and so uh i was like
yeah sorry i'm gonna contact youtube
myself because i don't i don't trust
this at all and so i closed the chat i
contacted youtube like hey is anything
wrong with my accounts you know is uh
everything's gonna be deleted he's like
no that's all good i'm like you're sure
this guy said it was and he's like no no
it's all good i was like oh
okay then i guess i'll carry on and then
i found out it was a big steal yeah
multiple people have fallen for it yeah
yeah i mean i think the problem was that
you could just even if you wanted to ask
an official person that youtube how well
who would you contact yeah i had to i
had to like do a web chat with someone
at google mm-hmm
how'd you do that oh is that possible
yeah yeah you can do like a web chat
there are real employees at google i
don't know if it's real
i i probably just might like the most
advanced ai yeah
[Applause]
i think within their website it's like
would you like to talk to someone so
it's like a pop-up
information and stuff and yeah it was it
was actually surprisingly easy but you
know that's i think that was
that might have been just youtube i
don't know you know i it's all about
that's the thing that's the problem so
everything is so hidden in secrecy that
if someone did come up to you and was
like this is who we are we're google
we're youtube you have a problem then
like most people like especially for the
smaller youtubers they wouldn't know any
better because they probably think to
themselves well i guess you know no
one's really told me how to contact
google i guess this is how they contact
you right and that's probably why so
many people fell for it yeah yeah oh i i
oh sorry did you have something to say
no no that was it yeah jim brownie fell
for it and a few other big names the
spiffing i think fell for it as well
lots of big youtubers fall for yeah it's
connecting